“SCPs will come and go, we know that.
But the most important thing in life will
always be the anomalies at this containment
site.
Right here.
Right now.
That’s Family!”
Thank you, Dr. Toretto, for that inspiring
speech.
Family can mean many things to many people,
and when it comes to the bizarre world of
SCPs: family can be found in some very unexpected
places.
Take the two brothers Cain and Able - SCP-073
and SCP-076-2, respectively - as an example.
Their shared history goes back centuries,
and from what little we’ve been able to
learn directly from the source: the two seem
to have the mother of all sibling rivalries.
Able can become visibly enraged at the very
mention of Cain’s name, whereas Cain has
a more subdued response, calmly but firmly
urging inquisitive researchers not to discuss
the matter any further.
Whatever bad blood came between them is not
fully known, but it likely has something to
do with the nature of their anomalous abilities.
Cain had the power to drain the lives of plant
life with merely a touch, while Able had the
power of resurrection: returning from the
grave every time he was dealt a lethal blow.
The two were natural opposites, and yet – they
were also, undeniably, family.
And their case is not wholly unique within
the SCP Foundation, as there is another pair
of completely antithetical beings in containment
who surprisingly share a family tree.
And much like the dynamic between SCP-073
and SCP-076-2, there was one side of the pair
that could express nothing but distress at
the mere mention of the other.
And it was, by far, not the one that most
would expect.
Enter SCP-682 - one of the most deadly keter-class
SCPs that the Foundation had ever known - a
reptilian monstrosity responsible for multiple
containment breaches, capable of withstanding
the total punishment of weapons both conventional
and anomalous, and hellbent on following through
on the personal violent destruction of every
living being in existence.
It is an anomalous creature so overwhelmingly
powerful and indestructible that one could
easily assume that it was incapable of fear.
And in most cases, that would be an astute
observation.
But not when it comes to the matter of SCP-999
- the tickle monster.
In stark contrast to SCP-682’s viciousness,
SCP-999 is a bundle of pure unadulterated
bliss.
Resembling a smiley-faced glob of sunshine
and honey, SCP-999’s main anomalous property
is its ability to bring lasting joy to all
beings that interact with it.
Prolonged contact with the little guy has
even been proven to cure depression and ease
trauma.
What’s more, SCP-999 seems to actively seek
out others to share these benefits with and
often does so through play or other forms
of socialization.
SCP-999 is benevolent in just about every
way that a being could be, and that makes
it very different from most of the sapient
anomalies in containment.
It is especially different from SCP-682, even
though they have a common origin.
While the family resemblance is far from striking,
these two SCPs are half-siblings - not as
closely related as Cain and Able - but that
is still a lot closer than most researchers
would expect.
Both of them were allegedly born from human
mothers who had undergone a horrific ritual
at the hands of an obscure cult known as the
Children of The Scarlet King.
As the ominous name of the cult implies, the
members of the Children of The Scarlet King
worshiped a nightmarish deity known as The
Scarlet King.
This interdimensional superbeing has become
known to the SCP Foundation as one of the
most threatening anomalous forces in existence,
and some have even suggested that The Scarlet
King is the ultimate threat that the Foundation
must overcome if they wish to achieve their
goals.
To put it a different way, The Scarlet King
is like the last boss of a traditional RPG
video game: a primal source of all evil and
suffering in the world, which must be defeated
at any cost.
His powers are so great that our world is
merely one of many that he aims to conquer
and reduce to rubble and ruin, and all of
us mortals can take a bit of solace in the
fact that the Scarlet King’s split interests
mean that he is unlikely to invade our world
directly anytime soon.
He is not without his schemes and contingencies,
though, of which the vile machinations of
The Children of Scarlet King were surely one.
The two ordinary human women who would go
on to give birth to both SCP-682 and SCP-999
were part of a group of seven individuals
total - all of whom had been imprisoned by
the Children of The Scarlet King and were
found in the late stages of pregnancy at the
cult’s compound.
Upon being discovered by the SCP Foundation,
these women were placed in containment and
designated SCP-231.
Over the duration of their containment, the
instances of SCP-231 have given birth to various
anomalies.
Most of these anomalies have been catastrophically
dangerous keter-class anomalies and have each
been the cause of hundreds of casualties.
Those which could be destroyed through violence
were neutralized before ever receiving a designation,
with the obvious exception being SCP-682:
despite the Foundation’s best efforts.
Even more exceptional is SCP-999 - which while
just as anomalous and nigh-indestructible
as the others, did not share its siblings'
capacity for cruelty and slaughter.
Of all the humans that were unlucky enough
to become part of SCP-231, only the mother
of SCP-999 was able to survive and make a
full recovery from the trauma she suffered
at the hands of the cult.
This unexpectedly happy outcome was apparently
thanks to SCP-999’s ability to heal those
around it, including its human mother.
SCP-682, the hard-to-destroy reptile, and
SCP-999, the tickle monster, are the two most
notable members of the SCP-231 brood, and
while the Scarlet King had more than likely
hoped that his actual biological children
would join forces to drown our world in misery
and pain, this will most likely never come
to pass.
This is because SCP-682 and SCP-999 are like
oil and water, and the one that has been successful
in rising above the other has unmistakably
been SCP-999.
This surprising truth became known to the
Foundation after a rather eventful cross-test
between the two most contrary spawn of the
Scarlet King, and the findings from that experiment
point towards a possible long-term solution
in dealing with the interdimensional elder
evil as well as his children - adopted or
otherwise.
The cross-test was the product of resilient
optimism from the research team, who, against
all odds, were willing to bet that SCP-999
could survive an encounter with one of the
most infamous Keter class SCPs the Foundation
had on record.
Nobody could be one hundred percent sure that
999 would come out of the test unscathed,
and there was not an insubstantial amount
of fear as everyone’s favorite glob of goodness
was wheeled into a shared containment for
the experiment to be carried out.
However, the mere presence of SCP-999 did
soothe a great deal of the worried souls,
which only instilled more confidence in the
head researchers that this would lead to a
success.
Once SCP-999 was alone in the cell with SCP-682,
the main event could begin.
SCP-682 had been subject to a wide variety
of cross-tests during its time in containment,
and having never met or been aware of SCP-999
prior to the test, was cautiously staring
the creature down: prepared for the absolute
worst.
With a beaming smile on its face, SCP-999
slid forward towards the reptile, causing
the keter-class SCP to instinctively step
backward in response.
There was something deeply unsettling about
this gooey little glob to SCP-682, but it
couldn’t fathom what from appearance.
The overseers of the cross-test were stunned.
The sight of SCP-682 retreating from an entity
was rare, to say the least, and the adorable,
unimposing shape of SCP-999 made the scene
playing out inside the containment area especially
surreal.
But no matter how unlikely it seemed, SCP-999
had begun the sibling playdate with an insurmountable
psychological advantage.
As the tickle monster moved ever closer, SCP-682
found itself backed into a corner.
With no further options, the reptile brought
one of its massive claws down on top of the
smiling blob.
The entire mass of SCP-999 was splattered
into jelly upon impact.
For a moment, it seemed as though that was
it.
The researchers held their breath in shock,
hoping that SCP-999 would pull through.
And then, their wish came true.
The amorphous form of SCP-999 began to reshape
itself into the recognizable form that we
all know and love.
It proceeded to crawl up SCP-682’s body
towards the nape of its neck.
Once there, the tickle monster began doing
what it does best: cuddles and lots of them.
SCP-682 was certainly caught off guard by
this unusual occurrence, and more than that:
it was falling fast under SCP-999’s spell
of benevolence.
The lizard began to stomp its claws, overcome
with sudden bouts of uproarious laughter.
It began to vocalize in a way that seemed
uncharacteristically enthusiastic for the
keter class anomaly.
“Happy!
Happy!
I feel so happy!”
repeated SCP-682, as it rolled around and
thrashed in the cross-testing containment
chamber.
The merciless tickling from SCP-999 looked
like it would be torturous for the big reptile
to endure if it wasn’t so much fun.
On the sidelines, the Foundation personnel
cheered on their wonderful little friend SCP-999,
as it continued to tickle SCP-682 without
stopping.
Some of the staff present were even sporting
custom T-shirts that read “SCP-999 literally
cured my depression.”
The tickle monster did have a large fanbase
within its containment facility, after all,
and returning some of the good vibes that
the anomaly had provided seemed like the right
thing to do at a time like this.
SCP-682’s fits of laughter continued for
a long while, and the more it went on, the
more it seemed that SCP-682 was becoming tired.
SCP-999, seeming to sense its sibling’s
energy level decreasing, ceased the relentless
tickling and instead began to nuzzle SCP-682
and purr into the lizard’s ears.
Slowly, the quiet and pleasant sounds of SCP-999
lulled SCP-682 into a peaceful slumber.
The hard-to-destroy reptile curled up on the
floor of the containment cell, almost like
a sleeping cat, and began to gently snore
away.
Once its older and more cantankerous sibling
had fallen completely asleep, SCP-999 slithered
off SCP-682’s back and settled down nearby
to rest its own eyes.
The research team couldn’t help but smile
and observe for several minutes before eventually
removing SCP-999 from the cross-test containment
cell.
Predictably this caused SCP-682 to revert
back to its usual violent behavior and a containment
breach ensued shortly after.
However, the casualties were kept to minimum
as SCP-999 bravely helped escort several dozen
Foundation personnel to safety by itself.
What would we do without you, SCP-999?
We know what SCP-682 would do without SCP-999,
of course.
The hard-to-destroy reptile would be far less
threatened.
While SCP-999 has expressed continued interest
in another playdate with SCP-682, the exact
opposite sentiment has been reported from
its reptilian sibling.
And it's not simply a lack of affection, there
is an underlying fear that motivates SCP-682’s
desire to never interact with SCP-999 again.
While some researchers speculated that SCP-682
felt an incredible sense of shame when it
was observed being tickled, this is more of
an armchair assumption that projects typical
human psychology onto an anomalous being.
We can’t forget that SCP-682 was born of
the Scarlet King, and while SCP-999 possesses
the inverse of its father’s traits, SCP-682
might have directly inherited the template
for its emotional intelligence from that very
same being.
While most well-adjusted humans try to avoid
supposedly negative stimuli – such as embarrassment,
anger, sadness, and fear – and seek out
positive stimuli i.e. happiness, pleasure,
security, and trust: alien beings with twisted
minds like the Scarlet King might have these
priorities reversed.
To SCP-682, all other living things are disgusting,
and it wishes to destroy them, but when this
tendency is examined with the context of both
SCP-999 and what we know about the Scarlet
King, it becomes clear that SCP-682 isn’t
an excessively prideful being.
Moreover, SCP-682 doesn’t believe that it
is doing the world or itself a service by
eliminating the aforementioned disgusting
beings.
We’ve theorized that SCP-682 and SCP-999
are equal and opposite, but if that proves
to be true on the level of internal psyche,
SCP-682 might compulsively attack other beings
for the same reason that SCP-999 comforts
them.
It is a continuous expression of empathy,
or more accurately: whatever one might call
the impossible inverse of empathy.
SCP-682 and The Scarlet King are not merely
indifferent to the suffering of others: both
of them need to be in the presence of those
suffering beings in order to feel any sense
of meaning in their existence.
After all: love is the strongest emotion,
but hate is the second strongest emotion.
Imagine now, if you can, why SCP-682 fears
SCP-999: a being that represents every unwanted
sensation and emotion that it lives its immortal
life hoping to avoid.
In the eyes of SCP-682, SCP-999 is precisely
as horrifying as the reptile is to ourselves.
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go check out “SCP-001 No Match For The
Tickle Monster!” and “What Does SCP-999
Do All Day?
(Hour by Hour)” for more adventures with
SCP-999!